hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong the podcast
where we take a tomato meter score we
say is rotten tomatoes really right
about that or are they wrong hence the
name of the show which today's subject
we finally got there everyone i know it
took a while but as we celebrate may the
fourth the day this episode dropped it's
kind of become may the fourth be with
you it's a national holiday of sorts
it's an intergalactic holiday who am i
kidding where we celebrate all that we
know and love about star wars today's
movie star wars episode 6 return of the
jedi also known as
my favorite star wars movie of all time
also known as my favorite film ever i
don't it's the godfathers they're
adorable toy story congratulations andy
i love star wars
episode six return to the jedi more than
any other film it is my favorite movie
and that's what we're talking about
today so we're gonna get into the tomato
meter we got two very special guests to
bring on and we'll talk about everything
that goes in to return to the jedi the
movie talk of it all we're gonna get
some behind the scenes who we're not
gonna have joining us today is
jacqueline coley because she's still on
vacation she's kind of doing like a tour
of the galaxy far far away so she
started out tatooine she's going in
order of the classic trilogy so she
spent some time on hoth skiing she went
to dagobah
it's hard to find even a rest stop much
less a showering facility on dagobah so
then she took off did some time in yavin
iv and now she's in endor probably doing
some sort of weird ewok tradition and
then she'll be back with us next week i
believe but today it is return of the
jedi
the audience score is great i got no
problem with the audience score 94
percent have at it
83
certified fresh but 83
which if you're keeping score at home is
the lowest as far as the classic trilogy
goes in star wars canon so
now we bring on some guests who i'm very
curious to see how they feel about the
tomato meter about the audience score
about where return of the jedi rates for
them because they are two gigantic star
wars aficionados first up is my dear
friend wendy lee zadie who you know from
the movie couple she's a film critic
content creator she does it all and she
watches a lot of star wars wendy welcome
back to rotten tomatoes and making your
debut i believe on rotten tomatoes is
wrong how did we let it go this far
well hello ellis and thanks so much for
having me i look i can't think of a
better way to spend time with you other
than talking all things star wars and
maybe argue about that tomato meter
rating
um thank you i don't know which team
you're gonna be on yet i have an inkling
so i hope that we're on the same side
because as you know i'm very passionate
about this and maybe here to referee the
proceedings is gonna be our other
esteemed panelist here you know him from
the hit podcast force center he's a very
funny stand-up comedian and he literally
wrote the book on star wars maybe not
the book he wrote a book on star wars
called why we love star wars ken
knapsock is here can we all love star
wars do you have return of the jedi
i do mark it's good to be here good to
be back and good to be talking star wars
with you not in a chain restaurant uh no
i absolutely love returning the jedi for
those that can see the video i know i
look like a guy selling comics at the
swap meet but i got an ewok shirt on i
even got my return of the jedi storybook
uh here i'm ready to talk about this
movie i remember that storybook now
wendy do you have any star wars
accoutrement that you would like to show
off to everybody who's watching us you
know it just so happens that i don't
really have much in this office that i'm
sitting in but i swear when you go out
into my living room there's a darth
vader helmet there is grosgu in in his
carrier there are late savers galore i
don't know why i didn't stage my office
today just to you know strike all the
other things behind me and put up like
because we have so many lightsabers
she's been keep watching
here's what's happened is it five
minutes before we went to air wendy had
a bunch of star wars crap behind her and
she wanted to clean up to look nice on
camera but then as both of my guests can
attest to when you live with someone
else who may or may not be a significant
other they tend to take your take your
star wars stuff and play with it during
inopportune moments which is what i
imagine is happening at wendy's place if
it's not uh your other half of the movie
couple it might be the dog so i know
that there's a lot of chaos but this is
why we like to provide a sanctuary in a
world that is torn apart by so many
different things at least we can all
agree that return of the jedi is fresh
or at least i hope i can make that
statement starting with you ken knapsock
it's 83 certified fresh in the tomato
meter is rotten tomatoes wrong about
return of the jedi you know as i hold up
my revenge of the jedi patch that's
legit from back in the day it that might
have made it go higher
83 percent right is that what you said
that's the number i did as ken is using
a choke force hold on both wendy and
myself uh i i here's what i'm gonna say
that's fair but at the end of the day
wrong i think it should be a little
higher oh thank god all right wendy
let's go to you now you seem to be very
relieved that ken said he can at least
tolerate an 83 percent what about wendy
lee is rotten tomatoes wrong about that
83 score
run tomatoes is certainly wrong about
that score 83 when the audience score is
much higher that's a problem for me uh
this is star wars we're talking about we
you know at the time i saw this film i
had never seen anything like it and
thankfully my dad sat me down and played
all the vcrs for me in order um
and i can't imagine why it's sitting at
i'm not saying 83
isn't great it is certified fresh and i
love that for this movie i just was
hoping to see it you know up a few rungs
yeah i'd like to see it get its due
because i obviously think rotten
tomatoes is way off base i mean look
yeah i get it it's certified fresh i'll
take it but this movie is right up there
with the best of anything i've ever seen
because of so many things not the least
of which is that this is how i
transition into the synopsis you see
man are we struggling in the galaxy far
far away at the outset of return of the
jedi because han solo has been frozen
he's it literally the the favorite
decoration by the vile gangster job of
the hutt and so luke and the rest of
what remains of the rebellion is
struggling to find firm footing because
guess what remember the death star can
you believe palpatine can you believe
the stones on this guy he somehow funded
with enough lobbyist money to build a
new death star so we're about i'd say
two-thirds of the way complete it's
complete enough to like when you go to
like lax when it always has construction
going on you can land in and out of
there which is what darth vader's
shuttle does at the outset of the film
and then we go to tatooine looks home
planet we go rescue han solo from
carbonite and the vile gangster and then
luke has some final training with yoda
to do but then it all comes down to this
epic battle that takes place on endor
and then you also have an outer space
battle and then you also have luke
finally confronting his father who is
darth vader and i didn't even tell you
all that they're going to be spoilers in
this episode because they're usually on
the show and if you didn't know that
that's how it plays out in return of the
jedi by now then might i recommend um
i i just don't i don't know what the
podcast is for you but if you heard that
and you sounded intrigued because you've
never seen this movie congratulations
you now get to go watch for the very
first time return of the jedi and
probably not be as surprised as my
parents were back in 1983 when they saw
it so we have our scores we have our
take on it but now we're gonna go to two
minutes with tim this is a segment where
tim ryan our expert review curation
manager breaks down what critics were
saying at the time of the release so a
little nervous about this one tim take
it away
[Music]
after the groundbreaking success of star
wars and what many considered to be an
even greater success with the empire
strikes back the general consensus
around return of the jedi at the time
was that it was the weakest of the three
still while critics felt the film
suffered from occasional pacing problems
many felt it maintained the franchise's
standard for eye-popping special effects
and built emotional heft as it went
along what's interesting in retrospect
is how many of the contemporaneous
reviews were a little wistful about
return of the jedi being the last of the
star wars movies we all know how that
turned out return of the jedi is
certified fresh at 82 on the tomato
meter with 97 reviews and it has a 94
audience score and just for reference
the best reviewed movie in the star wars
saga is the empire strikes back which is
certified fresh at 94 percent return of
the jedi is two points below rogue one
which is an 84 percent and two points
above revenge of the sith at 80
both of those are certified fresh as
well
so what did the critics have to say in a
fresh review sheila benson of the los
angeles times wrote with this last of
the central star wars cycle there is the
sense of closing of a circle of leaving
behind real friends
it is accomplished with a weight and new
maturity that seem entirely fitting yet
the movie has lost none of its sense of
fun however in a rotten review arthur
knight of the hollywood reporter wrote
unfortunately it contains the sense that
the machinery has already started to
wear down and the inventiveness to wear
thin the rotten tomatoes critic's
consensus reads though failing to reach
the cinematic heights of his
predecessors return of the jedi remains
an entertaining sci-fi adventure and a
fitting end to the classic trilogy
so that's return of the jedi
jaclyn mark
feel the discussion flow through you
back to you folks oh i'm feeling it i'm
feeling it all right tim i'm feeling it
because i i think we're already making
headway here because at the time of tim
recording that segment it was 82 it's
already up to 83
we are trending in the right direction
folks and so without further ado i think
it's time just to
shuttle right on over to movie talk
[Music]
if you aren't ready for a film
discussion that music gets you on board
but i return to the jedi it's just you
know ken wendy it just seems to be in in
our blood at this point because we've
talked star wars so much professionally
but also just like ken intimated as
friends gathered around some sort of
dinner table or bar setup and we just we
loved gushing about this so wendy you
were talking about how you and i
probably both learned how to operate a
vcr
watching these star wars movies watching
the classic trilogy so do you remember
the first time you put eyes on return of
the jedi and how you felt about it as a
film and then also in the context of the
classic trilogy absolutely i was quite
young uh when i when my dad showed these
movies to me so even you know um i was
living in taiwan at the time so language
wise i didn't really uh understand
the english luckily for me there were
chinese subtitles so i got to read them
but what really fascinated me was the
imagery that was popping up on screen
and luckily by then by the time he
showed me return of the jedi i had
already seen a new hope and empire
strikes back so i already had you know a
pretty good understanding of these
stories i was obsessed with the ewoks
until
i realized as a child keep that in mind
i was watching this as a child they you
know brought up their weapons and they
hogtied han and luke and i thought oh oh
no
dad
are these mean teddy bears that are
going to eat
our heroes and he's like you just you
just watch you just watch and think
things will be okay and everything
worked out for our heroes so i think for
this
movie
as a child watching this for the first
time we were watching so many things
there are so many creatures from jabba
the hutt to
um
the ewoks to the space battles to the
confrontation the final confrontation
between luke and palpatine and and vader
and
just kind of listening a little bit to
um tim's breakdown of some of the
reviews from the former critics and yes
i can agree a little bit that
empire strikes back is a little bit more
cinematic i get it that's the general
consensus and i am fine with that but to
say this isn't as cinematic i think that
is uh
i would have to disagree there is that
shot with um the lightsaber duel between
vader and luke and that is a hundred
percent classic star wars it's on
t-shirts
it's iconic
and and you get that choir in the
background and it just it really is such
a nice climactic swell to not just that
movie but the entire trilogy
can when you think about it in terms of
the first time you arrived at this piece
you got me by a couple weeks i believe
so where were you as far as your film
watching career as far as your your star
wars fandom were you like i imagine the
manufacturers of teddy ruxman at the
time where they're like you know what if
these ewoks turn out to be menacing bad
teddy bears we are screwed for christmas
oh yeah i threw my teddy ruxpin out the
window and bought an ewok after this i
was seven my previous movie experiences
were annie and e.t i believe and at
least in my mind uh it's a hard knock
life but i got to see this on opening
night my hometown i was seven san luis
obispo california fremont theater
downtown san luis the whole town came
out to see it so that was my first real
experience even though i'd seen new hope
one in a drive-through this was my first
real experience the whole build up
everything about this is how i fell in
love with star wars and literally uh
riding back home that night uh and
probably i think it was a volkswagen van
looking out a window and just staring up
at the stars and wondering
where this is all happening and what
else is going on out in that galaxy boy
oh oh you're just all the feels that now
it's starting to manifest itself in the
form of an odd salty discharge in my
eyeballs because
as the story goes in my family it's
funny bring up annie ken because we
covered annie a few weeks ago with our
dear friend alicia malone and
as as a we tyke i was a big fan of annie
and at some points in my career i might
have been a bigger fan of annie than i
even won star wars so the first theater
experience i had is i believe i saw the
empire strikes back on an air force base
and so that would have been in like 83
or 84 so a few years after the film had
come out i think my first proper movie
theater experience was saying return of
the jedi but even back in those days
return of the jedi like would go in
theaters and then when theaters didn't
have anything they're like well i guess
we can play return of the jedi again so
i'm pretty sure i saw it in like 84 or
85 and it would i mean it was new to me
and so it instantly the thing that i
loved about it and this will be a nice
transition into our favorite scenes and
producie lucy has told me that i'm only
allowed to say 17 different scenes from
this movie that i left that's that's
that's the salary cap so we're really
going to have to make some cuts
unfortunately the thing that really
spoke to me as a kid i don't know if it
was the color palette i don't know if it
was the juxtaposition of jabba the hutt
versus luke skywalker it might have just
been because i just started swimming and
it looks like when luke is on the skiff
he's he's basically walking the plank
but he's on a diving board and so it is
the climax of the first act where we've
successfully gotten han solo out of
carbonite but he's still blind he can't
really see anything lando is now firmly
entrenched as a good guy if there was
any doubt after empire strikes back that
i don't know if i can trust this lando
we can trust lando after how he bailed
us out of jabba's palace and so han and
chewie are reunited we're all in the
skiff we're presumably being pushed into
the sarlacc pit we're going to be
digested over a thousand years to our
doom but that's luke skywalker and he's
a jedi knight and right before
he gets pushed into the sarlacc pit he
gives a little
nod and a salute to r2d2 and that means
hey get ready i'm going to need you to
drain a clutch 3 from the corner in the
form of shooting my lightsaber the one
that i built yeah not my daddy's the one
that i built out of your top and aim it
and arc it just in the nick of time to
where i'm going to do this cool little
trampoline act and i'm going to flip
back onto the skiff i'm going to catch
the lightsaber i'm going to wreck shop
with every one of java's henchmen and
then we are all going to be making it
safely back to wherever the rebel base
is at the time i don't know what it was
about it probably something to do with
swimming probably something to do with
jumping and i love luke skywalker i'm
still wearing his shirt from return of
the jedi today that is still the one
that gets me every time it's as simple
as the salute to r2d2 and that's what
teamwork is kids
[Music]
cause
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a tough act to follow because i
just love gushing about this movie wendy
but if you had to label it to your
favorite scene in return of the jedi are
you going with that that as you said
that the cinematic epicness that was
luke and vader finally fighting for an
audience of one box seats being held by
the emperor yeah absolutely i think the
reason why i have 17 lightsabers hanging
around in my living room
as light as lighting sources goes to
show that those scenes specifically in
return of the jedi really stuck with me
and my fascination with lightsabers the
way they wield them um the way the sits
will use them versus the way jedi's we
use them really fascinated me as a child
and i think that's carried on
continuously in my adult life so now
that i can work my job and with that
money that i get from my adult job i can
buy children's toys to fund my
adult hobby addiction
do you remember when when yoda is
basically telling luke his sort of dying
advice is parting words or that um you
have to confront vader one more time if
you want to be a jedi like
did that really affect you either either
then or now when you're watching it just
like man this is really like the one
thing that luke
is a little hesitant to do in order to
become a jedi to get that black belt
it's like dude can you just give me 20
burpees and i'll knock him out right now
but confronting my dad that seems really
really tough does that still seem like
the ultimate hurdle to you wendy
you know it was kind of cut and dry for
me as a child i think me i was still so
shocked by finding out that he really
was luke's father and in my mind
somebody like luke
could not have a father who was that
evil to blow up a whole planet so
right i was thinking he's gonna go in
and he's a true jedi he was gonna handle
business so as a child i was actually
really surprised by i guess the turn of
events in my eyes when he really sided
with his dad and he tried really really
hard to resist you know the temptation
of the dark side to and to see how
everything unfolded to see it was vader
that pushed palpatine you know into the
pit as opposed to um luke having to kind
of lean a little bit into that anger of
the doctor yeah depending on which area
you saw this movie and can a very verbal
reaction from darth vader as he picks up
emperor palpatine ken before i get your
what your favorite scene of this movie i
i want to kind of piggyback off of
wendy's take on on the final sort of you
know lightsaber battle is
what in your mind is confronting vader
because luke seems to really use it as
an opportunity to see one last time i'm
going to go talk to this guy i'm going
to see if
it's as obi-wan says it is that he's
more machine now than man twisted and
evil but i'm his kid i think there's
good in him that i can find do you think
that that is confronting vader or do you
think that all luke had to do is like
show up be like yeah he looks pretty
evil i'm out of here and then he's a
jedi star wars is about hope versus fear
it's about finding hope in fear this is
my favorite scene in the movie too i do
want to talk about i imagine we'll get
to some ewok stuff later and i on the
playgrounds of my school mark reenacted
the uh tatooine select pit scene over
and over and over again but this is a
quinoa quintessential scene in star wars
it is hope versus fear and and what
you're talking about here ties to what
padme said her final words were about
they're still good in him obi-wan has to
take that and carry that forward and
star wars that has passed on his legacy
of padme mother to son luke here in this
moment still believing there is good in
him when all else everyone else has
chosen fear including you could argue
force ghost obi-wan at this point saying
you got to confront him uh he's more
twisted now like you said this is this
wonderful moment so that beautiful scene
which i think is my favorite shot in
star wars the chorus uh comes in the
first time we heard uh a choir singing
in star wars um but it is a moment of
failure for luke right it's him giving
into the fear his attachment to his
sister the safety of his sister that he
now knows and vader plays on that
because that's what the dark side is
doing and palpatine's just cackling and
watching that so when luke jumps out in
this magical beautiful shot it is really
him on the the precipi precipice of
failure because he is striking out which
is not what a jedi does they use their
power for knowledge or defense so for
him to confront vader he's trying to
actually uh he's approaching with hope
and if he needs to he'll have to destroy
him uh to protect the balance that's
what a jedi does there's light there's
dark a jedi stands before the darkness
for those not the darkness but those
that would use darkness to overtake the
light that's what he needs to do but
what he does and think about the the
cultural uh time where this was released
1983 george lucas was telling the story
of a hero's journey a kid that goes out
to be a great warrior like his father
but learns the truth about his father
and is told wars do not make one great
and his final act is is not so much a
confrontation in a victory it is
actually uh compassion empathy luke
laying down his life uh and this isn't a
time where rocky uh we got rambo we got
schwarzenegger we got this we got that
we got muscles we got everything we got
hulk hogan went into the ring you got
all these things and george lucas is is
putting this guy out there and saying he
wins through compassion he wins through
empathy he wins by laying it down and
that is what makes him a jedi i'm a jedi
like my father before me and that's when
palpatine distracts him that is the core
of so much of star wars that is why it's
the best scene not just in return of
jedi it's the best scene in star wars
your heat has made you powerful
now
fulfill your destiny
and take your father's place at my side
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
never
[Music]
i'll never turn to the dark side
you failed your highness
i am a jedi
like my father before me
so be it
that's a mic drop moment right there and
wendy it does seem like that
confrontation that as a kid you might
have at least i looked at it as more of
a formality it's like show up punch in
punch out but this was yoda giving luke
one last test and it wasn't just about
vader or palpatine it was about luke
standing as ken said right on the edge
of the dark side and to become a jedi to
get that knight hood you need to stand
right there and not fall in you need to
not fall prey to that temptation yeah
absolutely and i think that's why and
that seems i think changed a bit for me
too watching it versus you know when i
was my younger self versus if i were to
rewatch it now i think it hits
differently because as a kid i didn't
understand the the the pressure that
luke was under and making very difficult
choices resisting the temptation of the
dark side uh you know not to use his
anger and as an adult i really enjoyed
watching that journey because throughout
the three movie he's been through so
much finding out who his father is then
it's his sister
um so
this scene i think it's such an
important scene to see luke fully
graduate into a jedi knight and the way
that this scene ends up as we know is
the vader picks up palpatine and he
tosses him down to the furnace where
palpatine dies
and
then we have
the forgiveness or the
the tell your sister that that you were
right where we get to see
you know i'm not trying to judge anybody
vader not the most attractive guy in the
bunch anymore you know when he takes his
helmet off and so he's looking at him
and luke is just looking at what has
become of his father and
i guess my question to you too is the
one bone that i have to pick not
necessarily with the movie because i
think the movie does it beautifully but
even the way that george lucas the
creator not the director that's richard
markham which we get into in a little
bit but george lucas is saying that this
story is is the the rise the fall and
the redemption of darth vader
i'm not sure that vader was totally
redeemed because i don't know that you
can redeem yourself after what we just
saw in the last two and a half movies i
don't know that you can blow up a planet
or you can at least co-sign blowing up a
planet and torture
billions of people not to ruin mentions
tens of billions of lives and then be
like look uh you know what at the end of
the day my bad i i was hypnotized there
for a couple decades and tell your
sister that uh we're cool and luke you
and i are cool um i think that that only
redeems darth vader if he dies right
then and there which he did but wendy i
don't know that it's a full redemption
for darth vader i don't know that if he
survives he can just show up at work on
monday and everybody's going to be a
cool
with what just happened you know
no he'd be sitting uh nobody would be
one to uh sit next to his cubicle for a
few weeks
no no it's like uh you know hey hey
janice how's your day going well
remember that time you blew up the
planet that had my whole family on it
yeah oh it's going a little rough darth
can i feel like every time i talk to you
about star wars i i am that that brash
youngster who just shows up looking for
a great warrior and then and then it's
just knapsack chilling on a rock telling
star wars witticism so is darth vader
redeemed
he he is this is the morality tale and
plot wise yeah when the sun comes up the
next day you're right there would be a
problem and there's some new star wars
canon that carries on in which the
galaxy does not know that leia and luke
are uh the the offspring of vader and
when that's learned it's used against
leia politically and it has some
ramifications and so there's something
there's something to that and i think
you're right but this again this is the
morality tale this is how it's supposed
to be and he's redeemed by this idea
here uh star wars uh takes this idea of
destiny something we know we know a pop
culture right destiny destiny but star
wars is about choice i always say
destiny is what brings you to the next
choice vader through all the horrible
things he's done comes to this moment
comes to this choice i really do believe
uh the things he learned the things that
that he believed all the way going back
to phantom menace and schmie who was so
key to his upbringing it's all in his
heart it's all there and in this moment
the war that he's had for over 20 years
the war of anakin versus vader inside
that shell that he's trapped in he
chooses he chooses and that's the big
lesson here the dark side will tell you
it is your destiny you are who you are
your your grandfather is palpatine you
can't do anything about it you have
chosen this dark side you can't do
anything about it you kill the planet
you can't do anything about it kill the
past destroy it if you have to that is
what the dark side continues to tell you
where the light side builds the light
side carries you forward you can always
choose to be better in the final moments
darth vader redeems himself by anakin
coming underneath there coming out from
that shell uh and and and and choosing
good and and to that note yeah he's he's
a little beat up you know if you ever
were to see hayden christian getting
like a health shake in toluca lake you
might say hey you enjoy your good looks
now yeah
yeah yeah you keep sipping on those
smoothies kid because uh life doesn't
get any easier for any of us after uh
the tender age of 40. you know
if if you see me and i'm you know we're
lucky to get to go to these fun star
wars conventions every so often i think
we'll all be at another one in a couple
weeks it starts celebration in anaheim
fans will stop me because by now most of
them know that this is my favorite one
and they say well why is it and i could
have a different answer a different
scene but just because we're talking
about this epic
end
of this greatest trilogy of all time in
my opinion you look at it and i think
the reason why it works on so many
different levels is because we get to
leave this super intense more adult
themed battle between father and son
with the emperor cackling on he was
having a good time watching it but then
we get to go to watch the teddy bears we
get to watch the ewoks rise up and and
pull the ultimate resistance move by uh
oh you know superseding the odds they're
huge underdogs or bears in this case to
the empire but a lot like a war that was
fought a decade earlier that george
lucas may have based some star wars
cannon on
the stormtroopers were fighting on
ground that was not familiar to them the
ewoks know those woods better than
anyone and wendy you gotta think that
not only are the ewoks a a great
metaphor but they're also super cute to
look at and they do get the kids to
respond to them and they do sell a lot
of toys but they also serve a purpose
they absolutely do you know what i like
if i could
choose a spirit animal
from star wars it would be ewok cutie on
the outside feisty on the inside with an
everlasting fighting spirit i feel like
that is 100 me uh and i like the just
position of
something that's on the surface so
seemingly cute oh they can't harm me so
you immediately let your guard down a
little bit oh what are they gonna do
cute me to death uh but they do know
these woods that is their home that the
storm troopers were imposing on and
i i think it's interesting because you
were talking about how we go from this
seemingly much darker cinematic fight
with the lightsaber duel between vader
and luke and yes that is a little bit
darker but i don't know if just because
it's in the forest with the cute ewoks
and it's brighter it's less dark because
you still see
injury and death and loss on both sides
and like i
it was a little bit it was a lot sad for
me as a child watching this you know
watching the little ewoks fall over and
they don't get up as an adult it wrecks
me like like darth vader can blow up all
the alderaans he wants to you let that
ewok live you let that ewok live but if
anything i think that kenneth might be a
harbinger for the rest of the movie
where some main characters you're used
to some some ancillary characters that
we love may not be making it out alive
you'd never kill the dog but
occasionally
do you have to sacrifice an ewok lord's
casting was like i think han should go
and george is like i'll give you nanta
the ewok which nanta's death along with
optimus prime death and transformers for
the movie transformers movie haunted me
for years those two deaths uh look if if
we're talking ewoks this is the point
where i absolutely love it are they you
know they can you buy some wonderful
toys about them yeah but they represent
a lot first of all remember george
george and gary kurtz wanted to make new
hope and go on and do apocalypse now and
they were like we want to tell the
dangers of war vietnam imperialism all
these things ah you know what francis
you take that one we're gonna george is
like i'm gonna i'm gonna talk to the
kids about it uh and endor is vietnam
you can't get around that and some
people don't want star wars political
george disagrees with you um but what it
what it is so it's so powerful because
it is the stuff wendy is talking about
the ewoks are reminding you that
everyone matters everyone matters
everyone should have a say everyone
should have agency and you have to see
that the empire doesn't see that the
oppressive foot comes down to empire you
know who does see it leia leo organa
it's one of my favorite scenes in star
wars she's knocked off the speeder bike
we meet wicket warwick davis killing it
as an 11 year old who substituted he's a
substitute actor because they kenny
baker got sick that day he comes in
there
leia sees it she sees an ally she sees
help she sees someone that can help win
the war now again do they want to eat
han and luke and like yeah they do they
got needs they get hungry
i don't know i don't trust blow gray
yeah
yeah i don't trust logre uh the the one
whispering into troopers ears that's
what that scene represents that is what
the ewoks are they are the idea in star
wars that everyone matters well
looks like i'm stuck here
trouble is i don't know where here is
maybe you can help me
come on sit down
i promise i won't hurt you now come here
all right you want something to eat
[Music]
that's right
at the end of the day they're just
starved for entertainment i think i
think they're like look we're not gonna
burn them but we need that god to tell
us a really cool story because c-3po who
knew he had that sort of ability i mean
i would go to a a poetry night if c-3po
was there and i'd be snapping in the
front row
you look at this movie as
as like in the in the whole of it and i
know there's a lot of jokes about ewoks
and and the guy who we run into from
time to time kevin smith put a really
funny one in clerks where he's talking
about you know is speaking through dante
that uh empire's the better film because
all jedi had was a bunch of muppets and
i it's a funny joke but i think that
when you really look at it i think that
the shock value of empire strikes back
is that darth vader is luke skywalker's
father what that's like that's such a
huge draw-dropping moment and it's a
perfectly made film and so i never want
to be talking bad about a new hope or
empire when i praise jedi but i do think
that jedi is my favorite because i also
want to be an optimist and and and when
you look behind the scenes at the
creation of this film i still think
today i watched it last night just for
kicks not even because i was doing this
show i didn't need to watch it for the
show i i've seen it enough i just enjoy
watching the movie the special effects
still hold up all the space battles look
amazing the puppetry work by phil
tippett and his crew handling the rancor
and i was doing some research that uh i
was rather reading some research that
our hard-working researcher mark
hoffmeyer sent us for each one of these
episodes about the making of that
sequence where you have a couple
different rancor options you have like
the hand puppet rancor and then you also
have these like giant wooden sort of
stand-ins for the rank or that they
wanted mark hamill who plays luke
skywalker to look at while he was
battling it the whole sequence just cuts
together phenomenally well luke great
fastball especially if he's throwing a
skull but even in that moment we get
what's the guy's name malikili the
malaki
the rancor trainer i am instantly going
from rooney for luke to defeat this
demon to thinking oh no
what happened to the cute little rancor
is gone
it did talk about that that that upset
me too uh first of all i thought that
was george went which confused me for
years it's not uh yeah yeah that upset
me for years too because i was terrified
i i was i was a skittish kid you know
this uh and uh
that that that that rancor absolutely
frightened me so
and and i said richard markham is the
director of this film because he is and
originally wendy it was it's known now
that george lucas was sort of thinking
about tapping his dear friend steven
spielberg to direct this final version i
think maybe it passed through brian de
palma and that was like a quick hello
goodbye cup of coffee consideration and
then spielberg couldn't do it legally
because there was a strike going on at
the time of the director's guild and so
enter richard marchand
i i don't know who really was pulling
the strings back i imagine george had a
lot and i've read a lot of stories that
said george was you know sort of an
overbearing executive producer story
kind of guy to richard marcan but at the
end of the day this thing cut together
well wendy i guess my question for you
and then ken is does this film change if
steven spielberg does it is there some
way that jedi gets elevated more is it
just a different movie do you see it
playing out
markedly different if the legend steven
spielberg does this movie i mean
potentially we're playing with a lot of
what is here because it is the steven
spielberg so that i think immediately
would have gotten a lot of butts in
seats uh however
let's let's you know go with what we got
here and i think what he captured
wasn't and granted i think
when we have a steven spielberg film it
would have been
just as or maybe even more cinematic
than um empire
but here's the thing what i really liked
about jedi is it captured the heart like
out of the three movie this is the heart
of the trilogy uh because we're not just
seeing luke's journey we're seeing
there's just so many elements going on
in it and i think
that's why i try not to think about well
what if steven spielberg did this and
sure a big you know director's name
slapped on the movie poster would have
been great but i think
he really captured the essence the heart
of this film and isn't that a huge
credit to the movie that we have ken is
that i'm giving you steven spielberg and
you're like i don't want to mess with
what we got
yeah look i think the the legacy of
richard marquan directing this starts
with what you're talking about uh lucas
at this point is uh is not in the dga uh
he has left it not because he doesn't
love unions or believe they should exist
it's that he believes the dga no longer
served the purpose it's almost like
george went on to make three films about
organizations and how you should not
trust them but maybe believe in the
ideals we'll deal with that in 1999 2000
2005. uh but i i i i'm with wendy on
this i i think it would have been great
george and stephen clearly know how to
work to work well together and i
absolutely love spielberg and i think we
would have had some amblin magic i just
i i think richard marquan did bring out
what he needs to out of it i understand
some of the critiques is why up top i
said that 83 maybe is fair i just think
for the story it should be more you know
there's some shots that are kind of it
that that's not fair to richard marquan
he he had a a crazy
crazy uh
hard task to direct this film with
george over his shoulder i think even
there's a quote of him saying yeah this
is like you know directed to play a
shakespeare play with shakespeare like
here's here's what i meant it's so hard
but i think he's still pulled out of it
i was watching this comedy special the
other day called like dog's stepfather
and the guy on stage was telling the
story about hey this is my favorite film
because we win richard markwand
absolutely captured that energy wendy's
right there i i appreciate bringing up
the the bid i do in dog's stepfather i i
wanted to play it in in the context of
this show but a because i knew we'd be
gushing about this for at probably well
past our run time anyway uh also um bill
burr is the producer of my special and i
don't really feel like texting bill hey
is am i allowed to post this in my
podcast he's kind of in the middle of an
arena torso can the check is in the mail
um i have one more what-if question for
both of you and and then we'll get into
sort of our last you know rankings and
all that stuff
does this movie change
for the better for the worse in your
eyes
if han solo
dies because originally harrison ford
thought it was the right idea for
han solo to pad that there was a lot of
discussion um with the crew with the
creators what do we do with the han solo
character is it best for him to go out
with his boots on and to maybe give us
one more emotional feel at the end of
this movie wendy does this movie change
for you if han solo doesn't make it out
alive first of all how dare you
how dare you even utter those words
absolutely not i would have been
heartbroken
this movie would have you know what then
i would have been like lower the score
if han solo didn't make it out of this
movie alive i need the original trilogy
i need han luke and leia the holy
trinity together
happy victorious at the end of this film
it just would not complete the star wars
circle for me if that's
the way you know it it's another one of
my favorite scenes in the movie and it
is just that nice walmart photograph
shot at the end where everybody's just
kind of sitting chilling and you know
after after all of us we've we've all
been on grueling shoots before sometimes
together and that's all we want is just
to go across the street to whatever
tavern is right there and just just
celebrate what we just accomplished now
maybe we didn't you know fall in empire
but it was a it was a good day's work
put in and we want that party on endor
we want to feel yubnub so ken
from your perspective han solo dying how
does that change our perception of
return of the jedi if he indeed doesn't
make it out i think what it does later
on is when you start to grow up and you
get a little older and you start to oh
that's right empire is the better one
which by the way i think i'd say empire
is the better film too but that's this
very it's a critical look at it i think
i think the the jedi would have had more
uh weight in in some of those film
school discussions about well this would
just be supposed to show that there's a
loss to this but i love that george
fought against lawrence casten and even
harrison ford saying no this is not what
we're doing again it's this morality
tale for kids but i want that to to to
end a little bit differently and he's
not one for tradition this whole movie
is not a traditionally formatted movie
you got this little short film with
chubba in the beginning you got
something different here he's always at
play this is what the the genius of the
prequels are they don't follow a formula
they follow the story he wants and needs
to tell uh so that's what i love about
it plus it would have it's a it's a what
if i'm not going to play because then
you don't get one of the most important
things in the star wars story to me
which is han's uh cheek touch of
compassion on kylo showing that
compassion and the fate of hate could
can change things that can save the
world uh it's a big heady concept but
that's what star wars is about and i i
will always fight that star wars needs
to have a dark and gritty tone rogue one
serves that purpose but still ends with
hope star wars needs to always go
towards hope over fear and i think
that's what george was thinking about
and you know harrison was grumpy
come on harrison where does this movie
rank for you amongst all the star wars
movies so i i at least want your
favorite star wars movie if it is not
indeed return of the jedi we all know
where i stand return of the jedi is
number one for me and then you can
really take your pick of the other two
classic trilogy films to fill in the
number two and the three slot number
four for me is either force awakens or
the rise of skywalker um i i'm not those
are kind of like depending on the day
too so as of right now i'd probably go
jedi and then i would go
new hope and then i'd go empire but
again that could change wendy how about
for you what's your favorite star wars
movie if it is not return of the jedi
as much as i love return of the jedi
i've gotta go with the one that started
it all and that is a new hope that was
the first time i ever laid eyes on star
wars and that remains to be my top
favorite star wars film and then i
actually would put rogue one in there
because we uh love a good prequel and i
thought that movie was executed pretty
well and then we go chronologically for
um order of release then we go with
empire strikes back and then the la the
uh return of the jedi see you're just a
good old-fashioned new hope gal you will
have a new hope then you have anything
that like that goes right next to a new
hope which it's it's such a great
seamless sort of the end of rogue one
and boy what an ending that was to the
beginning of a new hope and it's like
that's the best four and a half hours of
wendy's day right there the best part
about rogue coming out of rogue one was
you don't have to go if it's the first
time you see the movie and your first
venture into star wars you don't have to
go huh i wonder what happens next they
get away you can just go and pop in a
new hope yeah yeah or you just hit a
button now god we're spoiled
you're wendy and i are still stuck in
our vcr days um how about you i've seen
your multimedia set up i've seen your
star wars corner that you have at your
house so
what is you you said your favorite star
wars movie is still empire yeah yeah i
look you know me mark i hate ranking
because i haven't had lunch yet today my
ranking's gonna change after i have a
sandwich in me like it's all about
different moods every movie serves a
purpose i do think empire works not just
because it's critically the best it just
it changed the game and i think you have
to recognize that last jedi is probably
at times number two because of this deep
philosophical deconstruction of what
star wars teaches us and then confirms
all that uh in the end of the film and
says yes it's important what this
franchise has taught us for generations
uh but then you know jedi return of jazz
starts to slide down mark but then you
know i have so much fun watching ryzen
skywalker that's like going to church
for me but so is so is return of the
jedi and that scene that is my favorite
scene in star wars it's the one i wrote
about it's number two in my book number
one you could see uh is a little bit of
a swerve but uh
it's the most important thing that whole
scene with luke and empire uh luke and
the emperor man i don't know four five
six one let me eat i'll tell you
i i also have to point out how much i
love a couple other scenes is uh
luke actually standing over the burning
armor of darth vader i think that is
just so
emotional and so you know for a kid who
saw the closest thing that he knew to
parents burned on tatooine to see this
sort of the the right way for vader to
go out where he apologized and now we're
just offering him up as i we you know we
hope in the next life he gets to regain
that balance and get that all-important
blue light around him we pan up to the
forest moon of endor skyscape and which
looks remarkably like seattle washington
by the way has ever been up there in the
summer oh my god it is beautiful i've
been to the redwood forest too in
northern california where they filmed
the indoor sequences and it's i mean you
can't belie it feels like you're on the
forest moon of endor but i will also
give a shout out to one of my favorite
star wars characters is yoda and just
the way that yoda goes out like an
absolute boss he he drinks his last
budweiser and then he gets in bed and
he's like all right i'm uh i'm just
about done here but uh there is another
and yoda in classic yoda fashion just
teasing us with the idea that there
might be more
movies to come somehow on some distant
planet
it's just uh you know it's why this
movie gets me in my happy place it gets
me emotionally it gets me just from a
fan of looking at cool things on screen
and
it's my favorite lightsaber can we at
least rank the lightsabers what's your
favorite color lightsaber can start with
you your favorite color lightsaber
i didn't have time to reach over there i
still have my 1995 power the force ii
luke skywalker green with the same
original double uh double d double
triple d whatever batteries they are the
ones you can throw at a at a outfielder
in philadelphia uh
it's still in the corner that is my my
favorite lightsaber luke skywalker green
that would be mine as well wendy you own
pretty much every lightsaber that has
ever been modeled after a jedi knight
your favorite color
of blade
first of all where ken where do you find
all the stuff teach us your ways i'll
i'll tell you
1995 i was studying screenwriting film
production uh starting my radio career
and next door to my college was toys r
us me and my friends would sneak out on
our education to go buy the power of the
force two figures in merch i bought that
1995 it has gone with me every day of my
life every apartment every house every
move and i've never once changed the
batteries and it still works that's your
buzz and woody that that's you it's been
with you through multiple uh versions
and phases of ken's life so i haven't i
didn't graduate college but i have that
oh yeah you know
we can't all have that graduate in life
ken with that lightsaber uh for me
favorite color can i go something that's
outside of the originals trilogy go
rogue uh yeah why not i gotta go with uh
the white sabers uh via ahsoka tano
that's my girl
all right i'm again gonna be boring and
go with uh luke skywalker green
is my favorite the blue is is a close
second i've never gotten to pull off the
green tie like that i always wanted to
have like a black suit and then have
like the loose skywalker tie but every
time i dress up i feel like i look good
then i look in the mirror and i just all
i can hear in my head is welcome to
olive garden how many in your party so
i i don't think i'm going to be able to
pull that one off at my next uh nuptial
ceremony but that is going to do it that
is going to close the book here for
maybe we could just do this like an
annual thing producie lucy we're just
good to talk about returning the jedi
once a year so we'll we'll talk off
screen about that that is it for movie
talk let's go to mailbag
[Music]
all right well the the odyssey of alex
hellyer's class continues because
another ketchup crew member is student m
who is in year nine in professor
hellyer's class
dear rotten tomatoes is wrong i believe
venom is way underrated with his score
of venom is a breathtaking thriller with
amazing visual representations yet the
rating is only 30 percent venom is not
only an awesome action movie it was one
of the most popular villain films in
2018 some people might not like the
movie venom because it seems rushed and
boring but different movies aren't meant
for everyone so people who love
thrillers will definitely like venom
overall venom is a spine chilling movie
so i believe its rating should at least
be higher than 80 percent and that is
from m who again is in alex hellyer's
class and alex hell you're a big fan of
ours as is uh the entire student body
there at that school so if you want to
be like student m or anyone in professor
hellyer's gaggle of students go ahead
and email us at rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com and let us know which
movies you think rotten tomatoes may
have gotten wrong or your thoughts on a
movie we already talked about like
return of the jedi so now parting is
such sweet sorrow wendy where can
everybody find you out there on the
social medias what are you up to in and
outside the galaxy known as star wars up
to too many things and not enough sleep
you can find me on youtube over at the
movie couple channel where we talk about
trailers trailer reactions movie reviews
and food vlogs uh you can catch me in
person at star wars celebration coming
up uh i am i'm so excited it's my first
one i don't know what to expect uh
except me screaming a lot probably over
everything i get to see first
celebration my first one oh we're gonna
have fun i'm gonna come home with five
more lightsabers ken i know you can
sympathize can the folks find you at
that wonderful convention as well and
where else are you appearing yeah in
addition to a four-center podcast with
joseph cremshaw jennifer landa you can
also go to my website kenabsuck.com if
you like music i have a radio show
called pop rock and radio on mix cloud
ken knapslock was also here make sure
you pick up his book why we love star
wars and check out his podcast for
center wendy liszani you can subscribe
to the movie couple on youtube as for me
mark ellis like i told you where to get
wife tour days you can just follow me
online at mark ellis live check that out
in the meantime rate review subscribe
all that good stuff that you love doing
to your favorite podcast do it for us it
makes us feel all nice and special and
for everyone here brian perez our brave
engineer producee lucy our own princess
leia i am merely mark ellis red five
signing off and saying thank you for
watching this edition of rotten tomatoes
is wrong if indeed you watched it you
probably listened to it in which case
thanks for putting us in your ears may
the force be with you always
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you